there's a new gender that has been added
to the list now
I think this is new there's a problem
you hear it described and it sounds very
familiar because this is how all of the
fake native genders are described even
so a new innovation listen I identify as
gray gender which means I feel ties to
certain genders but
um
it's really hard to describe it's really
hard to Define I just don't personally
feel like I have strong enough
um consistent enough like repeated
enough dysphoria to call myself gender
fluid and in the end I don't really care
how people perceive me the thing is
sometimes I do feel dysphoria and
sometimes it's intense so essentially I
will never care what gender of pronouns
what gendered compliments what gendered
questions
um you have for me occasionally I will
be feeling a certain set of pronouns
more pronouns do not equal gender but
for me personally they do